[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y esto es lo
que veremos hoy en aquí américa el
espacio para revisar en profundidad las
noticias e historias de nuestro
continente
empezamos con el histórico segundo
juicio político en el senado contra
donald trump un acto simbólico que más
que destituirlo porque ya ha salido del
poder busco en una votación consecuente
vetar la de ocupar cargos públicos en el
futuro y ecuador no tiene claro entre
quienes será la segunda vuelta
presidencial pero las urnas muestran el
regreso del ex presidente rafael correa
de la mano de andrew zarautz y active
una crisis política sin precedentes
el presidente juvenil moix denunció un
golpe de estado mientras la oposición lo
acusa de atornillarse en el poder les
explicamos el origen de las tensiones
y vamos de inmediato a eeuu para nuestra
historia principal
los legisladores designados como
fiscales en el segundo juicio político
contra donald trump expusieron sus
argumentos y la defensa del exmandatario
hizo lo propio los demócratas mostraron
a trump como un claro y actual peligro
contra la democracia quien podría
incitar nuevamente a la violencia
argumentaron con imágenes inéditas del
asalto al capitolio que los
alborotadores recibieron señales
directamente de trump y que él sabía
exactamente lo que estaban haciendo
entre los argumentos clave está el de la
representante de daiana de get quien
mostró un vídeo de los seguidores de
trump declarando abiertamente que el
presidente de eeuu los invitó a la sede
del congreso presentation y ante phoenix
notaron a lo largo de esta presentación
la misteriosa similitud una y otra vez
de lo que dicen estas personas
dicen que donald trump dijo y lo repiten
levántense y permanezcan detengan el
robo peleen como demonios trump nos
envió estamos escuchando a trump
y saben de los disturbios de ese día
dejaron al menos 7 muertos y 150 heridos
miembros del capitolio senadores y el
personal está traumatizado por este día
que mantengan su arca pero déjame jim
heintz americans el daño hecho a nuestro
capitolio el daño y el dolor a los
estadounidenses a nuestra fuerza
policial y a otras naciones que siempre
nos vieron como un bastión de la
democracia
todas esas personas arrestadas están
siendo judicial izadas responsabilizadas
de sus acciones
su líder el hombre que los incitó debe
ser procesado también las web
roger era un happy take my world
no tomen mis palabras de que el
insurrección ista actúa bajo la
dirección de trump they were here
fueron invitados aquí por el presidente
de estados unidos united states pero más
allá de los seguidores de trump se
preguntan cuál es el objetivo de este
impeachment ya que es un proceso de
destitución si él ya salió del cargo
precisamente la defensa del exmandatario
dijo que se trata de un proceso
inconstitucional
los abogados de trump además negaron que
él jugará un rol en la incitación al
asalto al capitolio y aseguraron que el
caso es una venganza política y una
cacería de brujas el artículo de
impeachment ahora presentado frente al
senado es
un acto inconstitucional y de venganza
política este increíble abuso de la
constitución solamente divide más a
nuestra nación cuando deberíamos
intentar reunirnos alrededor de las
prioridades conjuntas de este
impeachment es completamente alejado de
los hechos de la evidencia y de los
intereses del pueblo estadounidense
el senado de veras
votar pronta y decisivamente para
rechazarlo ninguna persona con el don de
pensar puede creer que el discurso de
president 6 de enero en el elipse fue de
alguna manera una incitación a la
violencia oa la insurrección y seguimos
en eeuu en san francisco el histórico
barrio latino está haciendo uno de los
más golpeados por la pandemia del cob y
19 cientos de negocios hispanos se han
visto afectados y ahora más del 40% de
estos podrían desaparecer para siempre
según la cámara de comercio hispana de
san francisco
nuestra corresponsal susana mendoza nos
muestra cómo intentan evitar que el
barrio latino pierda sus aguas
hace casi 20 años que lupita repite este
ritual cada tarde antes de abrir el club
malibú en pleno centro del barrio de la
misión ahora lleva casi un año sin poder
abrir y teme que este club histórico
tenga que echar el cierre para siempre
este no hay club tiene su historia creo
que tiene más de 50 a 60 años que ha
sido night lapso la mente en icloud
y pues sí hemos tenido problemas con la
persona que me renta el lugar porque
pues no hay ayudas como te digo para
pagar la renta para nosotros al menos yo
no he tenido ni ayuda ni estatal ni
federal
algunos negocios como el bar chavitas
han tenido más suerte que el de lupita
aunque sobreviven a duras penas
angélica y su marido han despedido a
casi todos sus empleados aunque pueden
seguir trabajando porque sirven comida a
domicilio
hemos tenido que cerrar un turno
mandamos a la mayoría de nuestros
trabajadores a casa
tristemente he visto muchos negocios
latinos que han cerrado y difícil y creo
que el crecimiento vayan a abrir la
mayoría creo que le cerraron
definitivamente
estos cierres permanentes es lo que teme
carlos solórzano que lleva años luchando
por los intereses de los comerciantes
latinos en el barrio de la misión
el barrio latino que es el distrito de
la misión ha perdido más de casi el 40%
de los negocios pequeños que han estado
acá por muchos años estos negocios
el problema grande que tenemos es que
una vez que cierran no van a poder
volver a abrir entonces hemos estado
trabajando empujándolo para que los
dueños de los edificios les den
moratorios en la renta para que podamos
ayudar a que los impuestos sean
diferidos y no tengan que pagarlos
ahorita muchos hispanos no saben que
existen ayudas estatales y federales ni
saben dónde pedir las o temen que su
estado migratorio les impida el acceso
la pandemia ha hecho estragos en la
salud de los latinos de san francisco y
ahora también podría llevarse por
delante el barrio más antiguo de la
ciudad
[Aplausos]
vamos a ecuador que está en vilo por los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales andrés a usted el
heredero del ex presidente rafael correa
obtuvo la mayoría de los votos pero no
el porcentaje necesario para evitar una
segunda vuelta los candidatos guillermo
lasso y ya q pérez están en empate
técnico por el segundo lugar de
cualquier modo el vencedor es rafael
correa quien apadrinó a araus veamos más
de la sombra del correísmo en estas
elecciones en el informe de nuestro
corresponsal gustavo ortega el recuerdo
de rafael correa aún está presente en
algunos ciudadanos que clavan la vuelta
al socialismo
andrés heras representa la tendencia
afín al expresidente correa un
economista de 35 años que implante a un
programa de ayuda social con la entrega
de mil dólares a un millón de familias
ecuatorianas ante la pérdida del 40% de
los ingresos a causa de la pandemia aquí
vamos a defender
una crisis económica sin precedente de
la que culpan al actual presidente de
ningún y no y demandan volver al viejo
modelo político es igual
porque se trabaja con el señor
que se ha asesorado por el señor correa
porque él sí fue un señor hay muchas
personas que están tratando de después
de esta pandemia recuperar lo que es el
comercio entonces sí sería muy bueno que
les ayude para así poder fomentar otra
vez lo que es su capital su ingreso para
seguir pues en el día a día
del otro lado de la acera al programa
social de andrés araus es cuestionado
por guillermo lasso es una propuesta en
el aire hueca con dinero que no le
pertenece al gobierno ese dinero del
banco central le pertenece a los
depositantes de la banca a las a los
municipios a las prefecturas y al
sistema de seguridad social del ecuador
por lo tanto ese no es un dinero de
propiedad del gobierno el actual
presidente del inh morero también se
presentó como partidario de rafael
correa antes de su giro político
que con andrés araujo aseguran no
repetirán
y vamos a colombia para revisar otras
noticias de las américas esta semana el
gobierno de iván duque abrió un camino
para la regularización de casi un millón
de ciudadanos venezolanos que ingresaron
a territorio colombiano de manera ilegal
una decisión histórica que pretende
mejorar la situación de estos migrantes
que salieron huyendo de la crisis
económica de su país
la medida apoya a quienes ya se
encuentran en colombia y a quienes
entren al país durante los próximos dos
años
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador reapareció esta semana
tras haber superado el commit 16 la
secretaria de gobernacion olga sánchez
dijo que el mandatario estaba bien y
fuerte
el presidente mexicano agregó que no
usara cubrebocas según él porque ya no
constituye un agente de contagio amlo ha
sido uno de los mandatarios más reacios
a las medidas de seguridad contra el
coronal
y en cuba el gobierno de miguel díaz
canel legal hizo más de 2.000
actividades privadas lo que implica una
de sus mayores reformas del régimen
comunista donde es precisamente el
gobierno en sus empresas los que
controlan en la economía de este modo
los cubanos podrán realizar más
actividades por cuenta propia hasta
ahora sólo alrededor de 120 oficios
serán permitidos para los llamados
cuentapropistas
y vamos a haití este país caribeño vive
una crisis sin precedentes desde el
terremoto de 2010 la oposición asegura
que el mandato del presidente juvenil
moix terminó el 7 de febrero el mismo
día que el mandatario denunció un
supuesto golpe de estado les explicamos
cómo se originó la atención
en haití el mandato presidencial es de 5
años según el presidente llevan el moi
sexto se cumplen hasta 2022 ya que si
bien ganó las elecciones por primera vez
en octubre de 2015 su victoria en las
urnas fue anulada por lo que el país
votó nuevamente y el tomo posesión de
ese mandato en 2017 para la oposición el
mandato de moix terminaba el 7 de
febrero de 2021 ya que cuentan los 5
años desde su primera victoria en 2015
la decisión de moix de no reconocer el
fin de su gobierno en esa fecha generó
una nueva ola de protestas a las que el
gobierno reaccionó denunciando un
supuesto golpe de estado y haciendo
detenciones los haitianos ya estaban
movilizándose en las calles
permanentemente desde 2018 pidiendo el
fin del gobierno de moix por corrupción
en un escándalo ligado a desvíos de
dineros presentados por venezuela a
través de la operación petrocaribe un
proyecto de hugo chávez para que los
países del caribe accedieran a petróleo
a través de precios preferenciales
cuando salió a la luz el desvío de estos
fondos y estallaron las protestas moix
destituyó a su primer ministro pero eso
no silencio a los manifestantes que
pedían la renovación total del gobierno
y mejor acceso a empleo salud educación
y seguridad y es que según informe del
programa de naciones unidas para el
desarrollo la calidad de vida de los
haitianos no ha mejorado desde 1990
haití fue la primera nación en américa
en independizarse en 1791 pero la
inestabilidad política el azote de la
naturaleza en el terremoto de 2010 y el
paso del huracán matthew en 2014 han
empeorado la ya precaria situación de
sus ciudadanos
y me despido con esta imagen que se hizo
viral en redes sociales road phantom un
abogado de texas accidentalmente agrego
un filtro de gatito durante una llamada
de trabajo por su vida gracias por
acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
américa recuerden que pueden seguirme en
redes sociales en la dirección que ven
en sus pantallas cuídense mucho del
coronavirus y sigan viendo france24
[Música]